it's been one year since the space
shuttle Columbia broke apart over Texas
killing all seven astronauts on board
the anniversary will be observed at
Arlington National Cemetery
mon-monday next on book TV author grade
clerks takes a critical look at NASA and
the American space program since 1972 in
discussing his new book lost in space
this is a half hour good evening and
thank you for coming I would like to
welcome you to a discussion with author
Greg Clark he will discuss his book lost
in space the fall of NASA and the dream
of a new space age mr. Clark's formerly
associated with the SETI institution is
also a journalist and has won many news
writing Awards we will start with mr.
clerk telling us more about his book and
then have a question answer session
please prepare your questions ahead of
time and use the center microphone so
everyone can hear it'll be located just
to your left when all the questions are
finished we will start the signing so
now please welcome Greg clerk thank you
thanks thank you the the book is lost in
space and the subtitle is the fall of
NASA and the dream of a new space age
and
speaking here in Houston that's a
perhaps somewhat controversial thing to
say because of course Houston is space
central Houston is a place where human
spaceflight started and it's where
continues today and I think I wanted to
write this book because I was someone
who was very young and very excited by
the Apollo missions men landing on the
moon and I was one of the most exciting
things I remember ever happening and I
think I thought that some other things
were gonna happen after that that we go
back to the moon that maybe we go on to
Mars that maybe everybody would someday
get a chance to go into space and that
hasn't happened and I think when I
started to think about it and started to
look into it I began to see the reasons
that it didn't happen were as much
political as anything else and that's a
lot of what this book is about the
political barriers some of the barriers
that exist in the way that NASA does its
business and the book also looks at a
whole community that's come up since
Apollo whole community of entrepreneurs
who are trying to do space differently
and privately and on the cheap and so
that book book really the book really
looks at all of these different themes
and I thought I might start by just
reading a couple of sections of the book
maybe designed to give you a look at
some of the themes and the first thing I
think I'm going to read has to do a bit
with some of the space entrepreneurs
these people who are trying to build
their own spacecraft build their own
rockets really do space a bit
differently so this is just a short
reading
Michell Burnside clap likes to joke that
he's found the perfect setting for
someone in his line of work which for
the past decade has been trying to find
the right formula for opening up space
travel to the masses early on a crisp
winter morning with the Frost just
beginning to surrender to sunlight
Burnside clap who says it's a family
name so you have to use the whole thing
walked me out onto a spacious balcony
just off the main conference room at
Pioneer Rocketplane the company he
founded in 1995 and has nurtured ever
since we rested our steaming coffee mugs
on a flat railing and from our third
story perch looked down the sleeping
town solving which has been pioneers
headquarters for the past few years Saul
Bank is one of the most incongruous
places one is ever likely to visit a
picture perfect replica of a Danish
village seemingly lugged over from
Denmark piece by piece then reassembled
in a quiet California valley some four
or five hours northwest of Los Angeles
solving feels a bit like stumbling into
shangri-la via Hans Christian Andersen
for burnside clap a cheerful man who's
never far from a humorous observation of
one kind or another the weird kitchen is
of Saul bang is a continuous source of
mocking perspective if you want to spend
your life tilting at windmills you said
this is the place basing your rocket
plane company in a faux Danish village
does make sense if you consider that
solving is only about half an hour down
the road from Vandenberg Air Force Base
pioneer briefly made its headquarters on
the base as part of a short-lived
experiment in bringing some
entrepreneurial burb to the Air Force
even afterwards the Air Force did mine
pioneer using some of the base for the
development of its rocket plane the
Pathfinder the rocket plane business
hasn't been easy going for burnside clap
since its founding in 1995 pioneer is
hung on from month-to-month with a
financial jury-rigging of small
government contracts last-minute
infusions of private capital and a lean
staff working ridiculous in long hours
for not much money Burnside co-op is an
insider's pedigree that seems
tailor-made for space he has degrees in
aerospace engineering and physics from
MIT and was a military pest test pilot
who shook the skies above the Mojave
Desert just like most of the Mercury
Gemini and Apollo astronauts did in the
early 1990s mitchell Burnside Clapp was
part of a team that developed and flew a
vehicle that was in every way that
counted started from a clean slate the
delta clipper experimental or DC ex was
a new way of doing space flight it will
be reliable inexpensive and reusable
access to space in short it was going to
be everything that people always thought
space travel was going to be the DC X
emerged from Ronald Reagan's Strategic
Defense Initiative called SDI the
proposed shield against intercontinental
ballistic missiles dubbed Star Wars by
its detractors
billions were pumped into various SDI
projects among them the development of a
reliable reusable inexpensive spacecraft
to support a concept called brilliant
pebbles tyent tiny spaceborne
projectiles that would destroy incoming
missiles it was decided that a rapid
turnaround spacecraft would be essential
to this mission the shuttle it was
agreed was definitely not that
spacecraft the DCX looked like a white
parking cone four stories high it had
four holes in its base to vent rocket
exhaust and retractable landing struts
that receded into the ship after takeoff
and popped out again just before landing
with pride the DCX team nicknamed their
creation the junkyard rocket since the
team didn't use a single piece of new
technology that said DCX engineers
freely used technology that was once
very new and developed at great expense
on September 11th 1993 after 21 months
of development by about a hundred people
the DCX made its first flight at the
White Sands Missile Range in New Mexico
the same place burner von Braun's v2
rockets were tested after World War two
the ship was piloted by remote control
by the Apollo astronaut Pete Conrad
under Conrad's deft hand that DCX
blasted straight up to 300 feet above
the ground hovered in the sky for a few
thrilling seconds then began to move
sideways and at swiveling jimbo mounted
rocket engines the dcx then descended
lazily and landed just a few feet short
of the center of its designated target
the small crowd cheered wildly another
crowd cheered only a few weeks later
when the dcx flew again only two people
other than Pete Conrad were qualified to
fly the dcx and one of them was Mitchell
Burnside clap it was an easy ship to fly
he recalled very very smooth despite
successful test flights however and
nearly universal acclaim only a few
months later the DCX was sitting dormant
in a shed at White Sands the result of
the complex crazy-making dance between
big government big money and big ideas
want to read one other short section and
then we can maybe talk a little bit
about some current space activities most
of you know that that mr. Bush recently
announced a big plan for going back to
the moon and going to Mars it's gotten a
lot of people excited about human
spaceflight again there are a lot of
positive acts aspect to this plan there
also some concerns one of the trends
that I point out in my book is the
history of presidential mandates to send
people into space for space exploration
and of course the foundation point for
those mandates was john f kennedy's
announcement back in that the 1960s to
send people to the moon but that
announcement and the motivation behind
it are not necessarily what they seem
and i want to read this short passage
that talks a little bit about that
contrary to popular belief practically
the last thing John F Kennedy wanted to
do was race the Soviets to the moon
Kennedy's vision is long been a clarion
call for space advocates both inside
NASA and elsewhere who say that all it
would take for the conquest of space to
get back on track is another such
commitment by another visionary
President Kennedy's true motivation was
much more practical but Soviet power
increasing Kennedy was looking for a
technology spectacular to prove that a
democratic capitalist nation could
produce marvels that the communist world
couldn't match more to the point for
Kennedy the decision to go to the moon
was a desperate political gamble made in
a very specific geopolitical context he
just botched the Bay of Pigs invasion
and Soviet missiles were looming in Cuba
the moon program was approved only after
virtually every other option that
Kennedy's disposal was ruled out as
unworkable irrigating Africa desalting
the oceans and other engineering wonders
were proposed before Kennedy agreed with
Vice President Lyndon Johnson's
considerable prodding to the program
that culminated in the triumphant Apollo
11 mission
the extent of Kennedy's reluctance was
revealed in late 2001 in a newly
declassified tape recording of a White
House planning session held only a few
months after Kennedy publicly outlined
his goal of putting an American on the
moon before 1970 although the White
House meeting included Lyndon Johnson
for whom Johnson Space Center would
later be named and several other NASA
and White House staff the exchange is
mainly between Kennedy and NASA
Administrator James Webb Webb was NASA's
second administrator and by far its most
influential in guiding NASA to success
in the moon race Webb more than anyone
in the agency's history is responsible
for shaping the peculiar blend a
political savvy technological
sophistication and public adoration that
has sustained the agency to date Webb
had the White House's ear like no NASA
leader since Lyndon Johnson was caught
once called Webb his best administrator
although often late labeled as a
pragmatist first and a visionary second
Webb tried mightily to craft a future
for NASA that would extend beyond the
Apollo program in bold fashion the way
to do that Webb reasoned was to ensure
that the Apollo program was not the
be-all and end-all for the agency but
rather just a desert dazzling glimpse of
things to come in this however even Webb
could not succeed as the Kennedy tapes
make all too plain the conversation is
heated particularly on Webb's part one
can clearly hear the anguish in his
forceful southern accent as he tries to
convince Kennedy their manned moon
landings should not be the sole reason
for NASA's existence but rather chief
among many priorities in the broader
context of making the United States the
leading power in space and critically
building a long-term infrastructure to
serve future cosmic expansion Kennedy
repeated over and over that where space
was concerned his only interest was
beating the Soviets anything else was
superfluous the hot exchange went back
and forth for nearly seven minutes as in
the following I'm not going to try to do
Kennedy's accent or James Webb so you'll
just have to imagine it this is Kennedy
being very quietly emphatic quote
everything we do ought to be tied into
getting onto the moon ahead of the
end quote James Webb practically
shouting quote why can't it be tied to
preeminence in space Kennedy loudly and
insistently quote by God we've been
telling everyone for five years that
were preeminent in space and nobody
believes us unquote as the date debate
continued Webb tried his best to sway
Kennedy toward a broader vision of
exploration and the establishment of a
long-term space infrastructure Kennedy
eventually closed down the conversation
the moaning that were space exploration
was concerned quote we're talking about
these fantastic expenditures which
wrecked our budget and all these other
domestic programs and the only
justification for it in my opinion is
because we hope to beat them to
demonstrate that by starting a couple of
years behind by god we passed them and
quote but it's toward the end of this
exchange that Kennedy's mythic
reputation as a space visionary is most
severely undermined
he tells Webb that if not for the goal
of beating the Soviets to the moon
quote we shouldn't be spending this kind
of money because I'm not that interested
in space unquote both web and the
current administrator Sean O'Keefe share
backgrounds as career bureaucrats who
were hand-picked for NASA leadership by
sitting presidents Webb by Kennedy and
O'Keefe by George W Bush given this it's
not surprising that Webb is o keeffe's
professed NASA role model he reportedly
keeps a copy of Webb's biography and
Webb's 1969 books space age management
near his desks if this is true
O'Keefe must find pause and Webb's own
assessment of the space program he
brought to prominence Webb died of a
heart attack in 1992 at 85 frustrated
that as about as his biographer put at
quote the nation he loved and served
have found a new frontier in Apollo but
it stepped back from the opportunity and
was the poorer for it
end quote Webb successors would learn
the hard way that presidential mandates
are risky foundation on which to build
an interplanetary future the first
lesson in that reality was the space
shuttle
that's what I thought I would read from
the book there's lots more I could read
but it could read it yourself and it's
probably more interesting than hearing
it for me does anyone have questions
things that we'd like to talk about
there's a lot going on now we have of
course mr. Bush's space plan going to
the moon going to Mars we also have this
Sunday of course the one-year
anniversary of the Columbia accident and
a lot of people in this town of course
will be thinking about that very hard
any thoughts questions anyone
what Bush said he wants to get rid of
the shuttle plan
in Bush's statement on making more and
going to Mars and building more money he
said he wanted to abandon the shuttle
mission and the space station right so
why do you think he wants to abandon a
space station that's what we've built
all of our fount our money around
through the NASA and everything we've
been building is for it's it's important
to understand the original origin of
both the shuttle in the space station
program a couple of months after the
Apollo 11 moon landing
remember Paul 11 landed in July 1969
that was the peak moment for NASA few
months after that the administrator at
the time Thomas Paine presented this
great sweeping plan to Richard Nixon he
proposed to spend about the same amount
of money it's been spent on apollo
establish a permanent base on the moon
by 1978 and Landman and mars by 1981 the
plan included a reusable space shuttle
to lift things into orbit and eventually
to serve as the template to send ships
to the moon and mars and also a space
station at which would be built some of
the other spacecraft of the used to
assemble satellites conduct microgravity
research at the end of the day nixon
improved one thing the space shuttle and
so for NASA the space shuttle was a hold
a placeholder until they could get
something more in the future
shortly after that Congress was very
very hard in the Space Shuttle they said
what is this what is this craft doing it
goes up it comes down we don't
understand the experiments it's more
expensive than it was supposed to be it
doesn't fly as often as you said it was
going to what's its purpose the purpose
it got was the space station the space
station was designed specifically to be
launched by the shuttle and so you had
these two projects very closely
intertwined and intermarried and I think
over time the original purpose of both
of them got a bit lost
one of the original purposes of the
space station was going to be doing
commercial research never happened one
of the purposes of the shuttle was going
to be commercial launches and military
launches after Challenger that wasn't
going to happen so both of those things
ended up becoming dead ends and it must
be very hard to think for people in this
town to look at those projects and see
anything other than the hard sweat and
blood that's been put into them but I
think you have to ask the question do
most people in American put the American
public really look at those projects and
see what people here do or do they see
something that's cost a lot of money and
that doesn't have the kind of purpose
they'd like to see the second point I'd
like to make regarding your question is
mr. Bush has said that he wants to end
the shuttle program by 2010 and get out
of the station by about 2015 the history
of those projects and human spaceflight
project says is probably gonna take a
lot longer for both of those things to
happen so it remains to be seen how it's
going to go
other questions
to understand is the US military
influencing masses development
well of course NASA was founded with
really kind of a quasi-military charter
I mean it was created in 1958 that was
the year after the Soviets launched the
first satellite into space and this was
the Cold War and this was part of the
Cold War
and so NASA was really created as an
agency to help fight that war it was it
was a civil civilian organization but
several parts the military were added to
it and very very early and one of the
first ideas for going to the moon people
don't know this but it wasn't to send
humans it was to send nuclear devices
and explode them on the moon's surface
that way you'd be able to show the
Soviets and everybody else who was boss
that was kibosh fortunately the shuttle
of course was backed by a lot of
military support and spending because
they wanted to be able to launch
military satellites there was a plan at
one time to be able to grab Soviet
satellites in orbit and bring them back
so there's been a lot of involvement by
the military I think now you're seeing a
much closer and more obvious marriage
between NASA in the military that at any
point since the beginning of the program
Sean O'Keefe the current NASA
Administrator said just after 9/11 he
said I think the military space programs
in NASA ought to be much more closely
involved we ought to be developing
projects jointly and you've seen that
play itself out in different ways there
have been some planning to develop
spacecraft that would serve military and
civilian purposes there have been some
other things that are less obvious you
may remember a news item a week or so
ago that Northwest Airlines was caught
giving ten million passenger names to
the US government for screening to try
to you know learn if there were
terrorists and passengers weren't
notified of this and was kind of a
breach of privacy well the organization
that was doing the screening was NASA I
got lost a little bit in the news so I
think there are a lot of these very very
close connections I think as mr. Bush's
plan moves forward it's important that
Congress in the public really take a
look at it and make sure that we still
have a civilian space program because I
think that is something that excites
people military space you know that's a
zone thing but NASA should be a civilian
program because that's how it was
created and that's what gets people
interested
he didn't say anything about educators
in space about educators in space well
it's interesting one of the things that
Sean O'Keefe did do very early in his
tenure everybody of course remembers
Christa McAuliffe who was the teacher
astronauts who went up and unfortunately
died on Challenger well that program had
planned after Christa McAuliffe
to launch another teacher and then
another teacher and then they were gonna
launch journalists and artists and then
they were gonna launch just kind of
regular people who'd be picked by
lottery and just to go up and see what
it was like to be in space well
challenger kind of made that very
difficult Sean O'Keefe one of the first
things he did in office is he says I'm
putting back on the flight manifest
Barbara Morgan Barbara Morgan was the
teacher who was supposed to fly just
after Christa McAuliffe Paula and she's
been waiting 17 years to go into space
it's interesting that nothing was said
about the teacher in space program in
the context of mr. Bush's space plan I
think it's important again I think the
thing about mr. Bush's space plan is
it's really important that the public
chimes in and says what they'd like to
see happen and if people want to see the
teacher in space program happen they
should let NASA know and let their
congressmen know Barbara Morgan should
fly I mean she's Christa McAuliffe got
more people excited about space and any
time since the Apollo it's a tragedy
that she died in a lot of ways but so
let people know
the questions or thoughts
what do you think about what's going on
right now with Bush why do I think and
do you think it's just so it just
happens to be happening this year
yeah right before elections and all and
yeah I have very mixed feelings about it
I think as someone who as part of the
space space community has hungered for
some direction human spaceflight
whatever I think of the politics and
I'll talk about those because I have a
lot to say about that I think you have
to take the kernel of a kernel of
positive thought out of it and say right
ok got a de minimis administration who
at least on paper is saying they're
willing to try to do something different
I think now it's up to everything to all
of us to make sure it's done right
politically of course it was very
interesting timing for the president it
is at the start of the election year I
think he might have been slightly misled
by people who said who told him it would
be better received than it was the polls
immediately after the announcement were
not very positive people were saying why
are we gonna spend billions and billions
to do this and we've got a lot of things
we need to deal with here on earth it's
it's I think very telling that he didn't
mention space once in his State of the
Union address and it was remember only
about a week after the space
announcement so I'm sure there was a lot
of political a political interest behind
it of course here in Texas and the plan
would would potentially benefit people
greatly in Texas it's an important state
for the president but again trying to
look on the positive side this is an
opportunity it's an opportunity to try
to get back to some of those original
aspirations of the Space Age to try to
go to the moon to try to go to Mars the
question is are we going to do it the
same way with the same paradigm where
things may not happen lots of money will
be spent nothing will be launched that's
been the history over the past 25 years
or are people going to try to force a
change
you're gonna try to introduce some
entrepreneurial work are you going to
try to try to really rely more on
international partnerships are you going
to insist that it's a civilian program
and not something that's closely married
to the military those are all decisions
that are waiting to be made and it's
very important that the public and their
political representatives chimes in and
make sure if there is if this program is
going to move forward it moves forward
in a way that people are comfortable
with and happy with excited about
you're saving
I certainly understand the suspicion and
I'm suspicious of it myself again as I
was saying before there's certainly been
a much more obvious attempt to marry
military and civilian space programs
since 9/11 I do think that one at one of
the key parts of the Bush plan is to
develop a fundamentally new spacecraft
that could go to orbit that could go to
the moon that could go to Mars the
military has been very interested in a
new cheap manned spacecraft for a long
time that's that's a very well-known so
to the extent that there's interest on
both sides I think people are right to
be suspicious and I think it's really
incumbent again a sound like a broken
record but I think it's so important
that people chime in and not take this
for granted because the money will be
spent the money is going to be spent if
Congress approves this and as long as
mr. Bush is in office however long that
is whether it's you know through the
rest of this year whether it's longer
than that he will probably have a
favorable Congress that will approve
this spending improve this money but he
and Congress are servants of the people
and if we don't want the money to be
spent that way and if we're suspicious
of it we need to let them know but I do
think there's some validity to people's
concerns I think they're right to be
concerned
if you
I'm sure you
well I think a lot of the book is
talking about how NASA as an
organization throughout time has been
opposed to much of what I think would
actually change things for the better
not only for NASA but for future of
human spaceflight
so certainly there were people I talked
to a NASA who didn't want to spend much
time with me because what I was saying
was not what they wanted to hear that
said the book is packed full of senior
NASA people and XC Nannette and NASA
people who were frustrated by trying to
do things differently and were rebuffed
kind of time and time again and so I
think there are people within NASA who
want to affect change I think that
there's a cultural resistance on the
part of the organization that was built
into it from the beginning remember at
the end of the day for all of the mythic
status that NASA now enjoys it is in
government bureaucracy it is layers and
layers of of administration of vested
interests of political interest and all
of those things become at some point the
greater than the sum of their parts and
they really drive how the agency does
its work I think you've seen that in the
wake of the Columbia accident with a lot
of a lot of the things that were
revealed not only about the safety
culture but really about how the
organization operates and you've seen
that in the Space Station program but I
think there are people in NASA who want
to want things to be different I think
they're probably probably the change has
to come from a much larger base of
support maybe than that's there right
now
other questions other other things that
people are interested in talking about
one of the things that's exciting for me
I have to say now is really the advent
finally of a viable alternative space
sector entrepreneurs people in the
private sector who are trying to do
things different it's very exciting to
see some of the XPrize contestants and
for those you don't know what the XPrize
is it's it's an attempt by a group a st.
Louis businessman to recreate the prize
structure that motivated Charles
Lindbergh to cross the Atlantic in 1927
and they're offering a ten million
dollar prize for the first company that
can develop a manned spacecraft send it
up into suborbital space which gets you
weightlessness but not orbit brings it
back down safely and then does it again
in two weeks they'll win ten million
dollars whoever does that first XPrize
has been around since 1996 I believe
that by this time next year we'll see a
winner because now the players involved
are very very serious there's some big
money behind it there's some test
flights happening and it's a very very
exciting time to be thinking about human
spaceflight and that could help change
the paradigm a bit tourism yeah
other questions or thoughts
well thanks to everybody I really
appreciate the questions thank you
Greig clerks is author of lost in space
the fall of NASA and the dream of a new
Space Age it's published by Pantheon
books a division of Random House visit
Random House comm / Pantheon for more
information it's been one year since the
space shuttle Columbia